hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay audio long
personal log
dr. Johnson I now have an ivory scaffold
I'm eager to bargain pretty sure is
generations their initial strength was
prominent for now the patient's resting
comfortably
he trusts Haden sound like hoods his
life in my hands he knows his part in
all of this and this says what are you
doing with your blade the forehead has
been spot clean and marks were you doing
not chancing to create a passage to
insert sample a done sound good
great job crazy guy you proven your
craziness okay what okay that thing's
gonna come alive I know that
did you compound completed one time oh
hello
my buddy mind for survivors I pointless
pointless oh let me show you how yet you
keep on going
oh come here I'll show you how FAR's
makes me think that we had to open
species I mean the only one who sees
that we have died out a long time ago
yeah I just have an accept or haven't we
stop no stop your struggle no our future
your future the future of our race ends
here allow me to introduce you to your
manatees child the child
place us yeah these aliens aren't your
children
yeah you better run oh it's alive its
alive I knew it I knew it
a super-tough or some stay dead
like that supposed to stay down stay
down
hey I'm supposed to run from it run from
it can I okay yeah I figured that
yeah I wanted to do that a few seconds
ago come on please please oh that way
wait I see something freeze you okay
I missed this whatever this is force
energy Oh use de force energy now - here
buddy
your men would do oh yeah no no no oh my
god no and they're like right on me
oh come on where they come from all over
I regard and I what whatever man
I pull honky bull honky hop down oh
where oh what's that
aliens
howdy-doo cutting matters going
everywhere okay put on a helmet
oh there's more of them okay that's how
they
this is where a flamethrower comes in
very handy
if I only had the like the the cutter I
would have been screwed there so Lisa
and Lisa sauce already whoa whoa hey
buddy hey just a hack okay you're too
fat to fit through the vents
ha ha ha ha ha ha oh I'm so fat oh I'm
sorry I called you fat
we still murder my face off now you need
to find a DNA sample at the gross why
quarry to lab records there's an inert
sample stored in the ICU a dr. Mercer
was apparently doing intensive research
on it yeah I've been trying to contact
Hammond but all I'm getting is static I
think you've got to hurry he's kind of
dying and this thing is chasing
bring it thank you oh I'm all done -
what was once your war and now fire you
just try it
listen okay here
no no say no crash no boom
say your prayers buddy it's an attic
hello is someone there
Carrie Thank You doc time
ah hello but how did you do that been
tough break so jelly
oh no oh so sad so know me i tenzin
generating
all of you all of you can all okay I'm
running using sorry to kick your body
all over the place no even have a head
ah [ __ ] it up me Tommy
I don't know phone ah use my status
Oh flying through the air I saw a baby
yeah Tapia yeah here okay where am I
going
Don keeps shutting down the door
protocol i bypass the lock
oh thank you so much all right you you
just you hold on there for a second I'm
gonna go talk to someone else about
something important
bye-bye okay whoa yeah whoa aah
where did he did he come through the
door is he gonna be like right there
he's gonna be running right there nope
all right ah okay name flambo who wants
some
who wants some I'm so slow oh it's
another one of you haha don't even try
it
oh how is it
and just one thing killed it before I
don't know why that took so long
all right you're dead now
Oh 3,000 thank you Anderson I am a gold
semiconductor oh whoa whoa I don't trust
you I'll trust you not trusting hello
lady hello
Wow you do not look good lady you should
probably lay down or something but not
there because things don't seem to be
going set up where were you when I came
here through here before uh I don't even
know I don't even know things are
getting downright freaky around here do
not mannequin me I swear
those guys are still in there let's see
safety let us save cuz I'm sure that
some spectral horror from another
dimension is bound to jump out from
around the corner by that's someone
that's chicken whoa
alright crazy guy was definitely crazy
for so long doctor jealous Massa ya the
specimen continues to respond to my
experiments yes so their fortitude
not to mention elasticity is remarkable
dr. chi I'm sure would disapprove but I
do not anticipate that the issue has the
good doctor is busying himself with the
marker as in that Meijer now he has also
succumbed to the same dimensions that
afflicted the college yes yes and he
told me had spoken to his wife but
Emilia kine has been dead for some years
that's it I think
now you think this has gone far enough
Oh screw you sir a part in the God's
plan embrace your own extinction and I'm
being locked out of those systems all
the air has been vented in space you
should be able to bring it back online
from the security station but you don't
have much time I'm kidding I don't oh
not this I hate these guys
god there's so many I'm Kai throws
something at you instead of wasting ammo
please to take that oh you didn't like
that did you how about that oh that
didn't do anything
boom oh yeah give me something else to
throw boom I'll just just die cut hate
you hate those little things okay I need
to get out of here
there was an oxygen recharging I'm in
that room so should be fun that things
the things No oh it's in here oh there's
a lot of things all of you just take a
moment take a breather I'm gonna just
get the f ef out of here
aha nope nope nope running run run run
run run run run perfect strategy ah nope
ignoring ignoring nope not my problem
not my problem not my problem oh yeah
home so you get out of here you've got
everything you need to make the poison
now get back to the chemistry lab don't
tell me what to do with that you're
cutting out him and I'm gonna try to
switch over Oh lost him
I lost the signal yeah he's gonna duck
can you scanning for his location you
have to get that compound mixed oh no
man that's so much better
I'm totally all about the pulse rounds
oh yeah you know what's up oh you know
what's up four hundred straight up yeah
sorry for your English than I just did I
didn't mean that didn't mean it at all
okay all right
Savi Savi say I know why it's called
lethal devotion [ __ ] alright I gotta
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you in the next
part
bye bye